good
[Music]
hello, how are you, I greet you even my
jaramillo with the most
outstanding headlines for today, Monday, October 5,
the metropolitan police
are investigating a homicide
near Alta and during this time this happened
around midnight at a party
inside a residence on  man in
his 20s was shot and died
outside the house the authorities do not know
if the subject was leaving or wanted to
enter the party the police are
looking for the suspect
and mean ice nevadas are preparing for their
event by window that offers vaccines
against influenza from
8 am until noon tomorrow this
will take place in the parking lot
of henderson party you must be
over 18 and make an appointment for
more information visit our page
news.com diagonal in Spanish
tomorrow  it's the last day to register
if you want to receive your vote
by mail ballot you can do it online or in
person at a v  voting even on
official election day early voting
starts on October 17
if you plan to vote by mail
you must have the ballot ready and stamped
before November 3
and now we move on to the weather forecast
and autumn is beginning to show with
temperatures in  high 90s and lows
rolling 60 degrees at night
prepare your coats because they will drop even
more for next week have a
nice day I am sal and jaramillo and this
was in snow in Spanish
[Music]